[Music]
bro what what are you doing
shells coming over to pick up some of
her stuff oh my god I know it's gonna be
kind of weird oh my god here for the
first time since when did we get a
vacuum I had no idea where to vacuum
Garret how did you not tell me about its
fact yes we have a vacuum can you pick
up that pile of clothes at least I
really want the place to look great bro
she's your ex who cares you gotta ya
sack up in these situations
stay strong I'll be strong well uh you
know we'll be strong together
okay the living room is done let me just
ah bro what are you doing stop messing
up my exoskeletons why why would you
keep your exoskeletons after you mole
this is gonna sound like super weird but
sometimes late at night I put them on
and I go out and I try to fight crime
fight you fight crime like my bad suit
scare and I'm Ben Affleck we got to get
these out of here these smell terrible
but what if Gotham needs a hero
seriously I'm about to vomit that's what
that smells Ben I've been asking about
that smell for Mom bro remember when I
was into street wear god I basically
lived its supreme hilarious Quinn come
on you need to be less worried about my
impressive exosuits
and more worried about why you're gonna
set a shell I know exactly what I'm
going to say to her oh yeah I'm gonna
play it cool maybe see if she wants to
grab a copy or something that's one idea
better idea slide your little body into
my 2005 spring summer house and I would
look like you ya hear me up and then we
get her neighbor Jake to come over he
puts on my own I'd Americana
I'm not calling Jake then shell arrives
there are three Quinn's one shell what
what what is this Michelle looks all
three Quinn's up and down and goes yes
please is this some sick fantasy yes
dude you're not allowed to fantasize
about sure and then I say she'll there's
no time Gotham's in trouble no open your
eyes right now she's my ex she's awful
but we are so close to making this
happen no we aren't because then I would
rip off your 2005 else you do not take
that on look shell in the eyes and I'd
say I'm so sorry I miss you so much
you were hijacking my fantasy and making
it really depressed and she'd say I miss
you too I can't live without you
and I'd say she'll you are my everything
I know I was clingy but I'll change
that's what you do for love you change
everything about yourself to be what the
other person wants oh I am you're crying
mold me into something beautiful bro
what shelter Garrett hello she was
standing there for like a really long
time shell did you hear fine yeah I'll
just I'll just wait here while you get
my things it's right there in the box
couldn't find a seven of your Frasier
complete series but all I'll definitely
get your new one really don't worry
I can bring it by No just carry this
down to my car please oh yeah sure I can
carry that don't do it bro I have to
stay strong I've got you back I'm
running kind of late so actually shell
aye-aye
he's not picking up that box shell you
have human hands and opposable thumbs
there's so much easier for you can do it
yourself
thanks Quinn yeah you're right it would
be easier if I didn't have scoliosis Oh
Scalia wait Garrett you should actually
definitely owe her that no it's fine
this is a train wreck I'd rather deal
with the back pain she'll wait I can
good bye Garrett should have helped her
what am i doing you know she has like
severe back issues
yes she's so adorable adorable was so
great seeing her I think I can still
smell her a little bit just want to hold
her you know feel your touch again
grrrrrr what Shell's bad I forgot my
back um--
ah see Gare I knew we didn't have a
vacuum guys Garrett's going through a
lot right now let's let's really let him
know how pathetic he is in the comments
below and I will I'll read I'll read it
back to him
[Music]